Let's go next to, uh, Oh, you know what?
Let's go to Dante from Florida who often has
interesting takes.
We haven't heard from him for a while.
Dante is a Bernie supporter who at one point
flirted with supporting tool C but now he
is strongly Bernie.
Right.
Dante?
I think this time I've got it right.
Okay.
Uh, I was never really flirting with splitting
pills.
The Gabbert I just always liked what she was
doing with the candidate candidacy and the
foreign policy issues that she brought up.
So I always try to give her some attention
when it's, when I get the chance.
Alright.
But you were never considering supporting
her, you were always Bernie then?
Yeah, it was always burning.
Gotcha.
Okay.
What's going on?
Dante?
Tell
me.
That was actually, um, something I wanted
to ask you about because I wanted you to clarify
your position about not endorsing a candidate
in the primary cause it didn't really make
sense to me.
So if you could explain that,
what do you want me to explain
your reasoning for why you don't want to support
a candidate or endorse a candidate or which
you think it might lead to?
Cause I think from the explanation, if I heard
you, you said you don't want to add to the,
the circular firing squad on the left or something
like that by uh, supporting one candidate
over the other.
Yeah.
Listen, I mean I'm nobody, I'm just a guy
who's analyzing politics.
Everybody who watches my show I think understands
my positions.
You know, I've seen that there has been an
attempt lately to smear me as saying that
Bernie and Warren are the same.
It's like, you know, I've been clear they're
not the same.
Bernie comes from a far more left place than
Elizabeth Warren.
A lot of their policies today are very similar,
but you know, for example, Elizabeth Warren
voted in favor of a, a scaling up funding
for the military.
Something that I'm against.
Bernie voted against it.
Like they're not the same.
I've been, I've been abundantly clear at this
point.
I just like, what do, what do we gain my,
by me coming out and saying, I am endorsing
this person over that person when the truth
is I'm going to vote for whoever is the eventual
democratic nominee.
I'm not going to hide who I vote for in the
primary.
I mean I'm just, I'm covering the issues and
the candidates.
I just don't see what advantage there is to
me now coming out and saying I'm all about
this candidate over that candidate.
I mean listen, like it's no secret.
I've made it clear.
Bernie is to the left of Elizabeth Warren
and I would vote for either of them and I
think it's imperative that we remove Donald
Trump.
Like what?
What would an endorsement do it?
What would you like?
Would it make a difference to you if I endorsed
one person or another?
Like you're supporting Bernie, you know that
that's fine.
It's not really the endorsement part.
It's more that you have a show and I think
it's important to be crystal clear about it
and leave no room for ambiguity in the audience.
That brief hand is clearly better.
You just a better candidate.
It's not that he does, he's good on some issues
and he's better than it was a bit worn or
some issues and she's pretty good on a day.
She's like, it's not even close.
Bernie Sanders.
Well, but, but Dante, you understand that
that's, that's your opinion, right?
But you, you say you, you host a, uh, program
in your social Democrat, and if you're a social
Democrat, it's not really close.
You say that Bernie Sanders is more far, he's
more left.
So by your estimation, that would mean he's
better cause you, you're a social Democrats.
So you moved the social democratic ideology
of, uh, like social democratic economic reform
and not as interventionist foreign policy
and a progressive tax system if the best way
to run the country.
And Bernie Sanders is more aligned with you
on those issues.
So he's the best candidate.
So I guess that's the point I'm trying to
make is it's not that I think you should endorse
him because of a boost that I think it would
give to Bernie Sanders.
I think it's just important to be clear that
if you're someone who wants real, like structural
change, fundamental change in, in us politics,
revolutionary like a political revolution,
it's not like you can just, Oh, choose either
one and it'll be basically the same or be
close to the same.
It's very busy.
Very big difference,
but Dante, let me ask you, let me ask you
a question.
This is a thought experiment.
Okay, so don't, don't go crazy and I don't
want people in the audience to go crazy.
Let's imagine we all agree without placing
a value judgment on anything.
We agree Bernie is to the left of war and
it sounds like you and I are on the same page
about that, right?
You said it and I'm saying it now.
Dante, are you still there?
You get it?
No, but hold on Dante, but what we're just
starting, I'm just, I'm laying it out for
you.
You and I both agree.
Bernie is to the left Doug Warren, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Imagine that we became convinced that even
though Bernie is further to the left of Warren,
this is hypothetical, that Warren's policy
is more likely to become a reality for whatever
reason.
Right.
This is hypothetical.
Would it then still be just as clear to you
that that we are better off by putting in
someone who is further to the left but less
likely to accomplish things?
This is just a hypothetical.
This is just me saying just because we identify
who's further left, that's not all there is
to it.
Would you agree that there's some element
there that we would, we would have to consider
about that
in the hypothetical, but here in the, in the
real world, in the 2020 primary and we can,
we can look at their record and we could look
at what they plan on doing.
And Bernie Sanders, even though his policies
could with see more radical, he has a better
chance of fascinated because he has a actual
plan doing it.
Elizabeth Warren, she has not, uh, really
explain how she wants to get any of these
things done because she's not in favor of,
of primary incorporate Democrats like Bernie
Sanders.
If he's not, she's not going to, uh, bust
up the establishment like Bernie Sanders is.
He's not going to, she's not going to do a
rallies in Joel Mason state when he votes
against Medicare for all, like Bernie Sanders
said he would.
So Bernie Sanders is bringing grassroots pressure
so he, his policies are better and he has
a better chance of passing it.
He has a,
okay.
But again, Dante, that's, that's your, you
seem to be mistaking.
So I'm trying to have a conversation with
you about what you first brought up, which
is just about, you know, the, the, the idea
of whether I should or shouldn't be endorsing
someone, but now you're just making it, you're
saying, well, your opinion is a, B, and C
about Bernie, but I'm trying to have a different
conversation with you.
You know what I mean?
I think we're talking past each other.
No, uh, it's not that I'm, Chris wasn't your
opinion, you just brought up the fact that
it's, it might not be crystal clear that,
that Bernie Sanders is the best because she
might be able to get her.
It's not about best.
All right.
Listen.
Well, Dante, I think the, the takeaway I got
a lot of people holding, so I'm going to let
you go.
But the takeaway is you think that morally
I should be making an endorsement on the program.
No, it's not more where we, I think that you
should just be clear with the audience and
make sure that there's no room for interpretation.
Elizabeth Warren, she's not going to challenge
the political establishment.
I, I believe that.
I've been clear with that.
So my, if you go back Dante, to my first,
see, this is the problem I have that I am
being clear, but there's a lot of propaganda
misstating my position.
So for example, if you go back to the first
clip I did about, it's called something like,
there are serious differences between Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders.
The primary thing that I stayed is that although
they've come close on policy in 2019 now 2020
Bernie's approach is of totally read that
the system is broken and you need to change
the system at its core.
Whereas Elizabeth Warren comes from the camp
of fixing the things about the system that
are broken.
In my first clip pointing out the differences
between the two of them, I did exactly what
you're pointing out.
I haven't done,
I'm not saying you have an identity, but I'm
saying,
well you just said it, Dante,
that's you should be clear in, cause that's,
it's not just me.
Other people who watch your show come with
the same takeaway.
All right, well listen, do you know other
people?
All right.
Dante, point taken.
Let's make it about, let's make it about you.
I appreciate what you're saying and don't
worry.
You're going to know who I vote.
Vote for that, I promise you.
All right, Dante, thank you very much.
Let's take a quick break.
If you are holding, don't hang up because
we will be going right back to the phones
after this.